es gibt eine neue studie zum
interstellaren objekt um uhr woher kommt
es und kann es natürlich ein ursprungs
sein oder ist es doch eher eine alien
sonde oder ein bruchstück davon liegt um
science-fiction hier gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonnenten kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen
die spekulationen um das interstellare
objekte humor reißen nicht ab es ist zu
faszinierend und es birgt zumindest zwei
rätsel woher kommt es und wie konnte es
zu uns gelangen und was ist beim
vorbeiflug an der sonne passiert da hat
es nämlich stark beschleunigt und bis
heute gibt es keine erklärung
brainloop harvard professor und leiter
der abteilung astronomie dort hatte die
these aufgestellt dass es sich um eine
sonder handeln könnte von außerirdischen
gebaut denn so seine schlussfolgerung
die beschleunigung durch die sonne ist
nur zu erklären wenn das objekt extrem
dünn ist wie ein künstlich hergestelltes
licht segel bei uns im interview
zitierte er sherlock holmes wenn man das
unmögliche ausgeschlossen hat muss das
was übrig bleibt die wahrheit sein so
unwahrscheinlich sie auch klingen mag
denn beim vorbeiflug wurde nichts
beobachtet dass auf einen natürlichen
effekt wie eine ausgasung schließen ließ
die jetzt veröffentlichte studie the
natural history of humor beschäftigt
sich mit der herkunft und den
eigenschaften des objektes denn auch
hier sei eine unwahrscheinlichkeit ein
zufälliger durchflug eines solchen
objektes ist nur schwer erklärbar dass
nach bisherigen annahmen dafür nicht
genügend objekte im all geben würde eine
astronomie team hat sich das objekt
jetzt vorgenommen und alle eigenschaften
akribisch untersucht das internationale
team veröffentlichte die studie am
montag im fachmagazin nature astronomie
und vermutet einen natürlichen ursprung
einer der astronomie zu knight von der
university of maryland dazu in nature
astronomie humor ist rötlich und vielen
objekten die wir in unserem sonnensystem
bereits entdeckt haben ähnlich die
hypothese vom alien raumschiff ist eine
lustige idee aber unsere analyse legt
nahe dass es eine ganze menge natürliche
phänomene gibt die
das alles erklären können und die
herkunft und beschleunigung in richtung
unseres sonnensystems können zum
beispiel durch einen gasplaneten
erklärbar sein der das rotierende objekt
das war ja auch eine der seltsam
eigenschaften mit seiner großen
gravitation aus seinem sternensystem zu
uns katapultiert hat doch ein rätsel
bleibt weiterhin und so ist die these
von der alien sondern nicht ganz vom
tisch was hat die sonde bei ihrem
vorbeiflug an der sonne so stark
beschleunigt diese frage konnte immer
noch nicht geklärt werden es bleibt also
spannend ihr wollt einen klicks um
nature kanal das habt ihr in zahlreichen
kommentaren nachrichten auf der logan
und mails bekundet ihr bekommt ihn denn
neben humor gibt es auch eine
dramatische meldung heute zum thema
klimawandel
die verpflichtung zum klima schaden
moment nation verpflichten sich dem
klima zu schaden genau so ist es leider
darüber mehr hier bei pixum nature also
unbedingt draufklicken anschauen und
unbedingt klick zum major abonnieren und
weitererzählen es ist wichtig um mehr
informationen zum thema zu verbreiten
bis dann bleibt dran